- Well wait, speaking of Dan's dad,
he told a story about
Dan the first time he was
at our show.
So let's see that.
Yeah.
- When my son was 15
and he was going to come
with us in Los Angeles.
We went down for the premiere.
- Yeah.
- Of the movie.
And the night before the premiere he said
he was on the phone call with
his friend back in Toronto
and they said, "Well, what's going on?"
He said, "Well, I'm going to
the premiere of "American Pie"
tomorrow night with my folks."
And the friend said, "Oh,
don't see it with your folks."
(audience laughs)
- Did you not?
Did you not go?
- No.
Absolutely not.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- Absolutely not, no.
I called a friend.
They had just seen like an
advanced screening of it
and said, "Run in the opposite direction
of wherever your parents are
in relation to that film."
And I did.
And I have yet to see it with them.
I did end up seeing it.
For most of my high school life,
people thought the movie was
like a biography of my life.
- Yeah.
(audience laughs)
That is unfortunate.
- Which is really unfortunate.
- That's unfortunate.
- Because I would've
killed to have had a life
that interesting.
(audience laughs)
- And why apple pie? Yeah.
- I don't even know about the
ingredients of an apple pie,
but that's a whole other conversation.
(audience laughs)
- I think my mother's the opposite.
I would be fine I think in that scenario.
I think my mother would die.
- Okay.
You would be fine.
- I'm very open.
I'm very open.
I will talk to my mother
about anything.
- [Dan] Everything.
- So will my sister
and my mother hates it.
- [Dan] Wow.
- Like with a capital H.
- [Dan] Okay.
- Yeah.
- I don't have that dynamic.
My dad is very sweet.
But no, there was no...
- I have no problem.
I could talk about anything with her.
- [Dan] Oh great.
- Like literally anything.
And I try, but she is like,
your mouth is moving, stop.
- She's the opposite
of what this movie was to me.
- Yeah, she's not into it.
So I would've gone to the premiere.
Anyway, your dad's in a
(beep) cool, awesome movie.
I would've gone.
- Yeah, he was.
Yeah, you know, it's a weird thing
to grow up watching your
dad just hand out porn
to some other kid.
(audience laughs)